hello everyone I hope you're all
enjoying your Sunday because it's about
to get a lot better now we have a very
nice game between all areas of Fallujah
and initially from the finals of the
Chesbrough Invitational Tournament there
there are so many Invitational
tournaments online that it's simply
impossible to cover them all but when a
game nice as this one is played of
course we are going to cover it so like
I said from the finals and it's quite
the game it's a blitz game since the
entire tournament it's a blitz
tournament and it's another Berlin like
we've seen in the previous videos we
lure versus Carson and more and more
interesting games happen that start from
the Berlin so I have no idea why that is
but it just is so getting straight to
the game Ali Reza with the white pieces
opens with E 4 we have V 5 by giri night
of three nights the c6 and Bishop to b5
the Royal Lopez is on the board Knight
of 6 and D 3 and we have Bishop to c5
and now there are a lot of popular
options here see three castles
characters in c6 is popular but here
I'll erase it goes for Bishop to a4 so
the unprovoked Bishop retreat which is
rare but it's not a new move we have
castles in now white also castles d6 by
Geary and c3 now making room for the
light square bishop we have Knight to e7
now preparing c6 and d5 to start
expanding in the center and Knight B to
d2 and there is a game cardigan versus
Yaka mango from the world blitz
championship 2018 we're Knight to g6
with split but here we have Bishop to b6
by Gary and it is as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game so Alireza
continues developing we have rook e1
adding more defense to be for pawn
before pushing d4 and here at c6 Knight
to g4 going after the f2 pawn doesn't do
anything if you go for this then just
before you block the bishop and you kick
away the night with h3 and the next move
so not really doing anything we have c6
and the h3 now taking away the g4 Square
from blacks pieces we have Knight to g6
and now at Bishop to c2 so still
preparing d4 we have rook to e8 and now
that the d4 move has been
efficiently prepared we have d4e captor
son d4 we have sea capture son d4 end
now d5 so are hoping for a trade in the
center to release some tension from the
position but of course ePHI valiree's
are not interested in that we have night
to h5 going after the f4 square and
night the b3 now we have night h2 f4 and
now Bishop to e3 so continuing
development adding one more defender to
d4 pawn and f6 now Gary strikes in the
center as he needs a way to get a get
rid of this stronger central areas are
created we have each captures an f6
Queen captures and now comes the bishop
character son f4 and now we route
characters any one Queen captures and
the problem is you cannot capture on f4
with the night because if you do now you
just lose the game on the spot because
of Queen e8 check and after you block
this Bishop captures on h7 deflects the
King from the defense of the black Queen
and you lose the Queen and of course the
game so after Queen captures any one
Queen captures and a4 was played but now
you allow a different idea Bishop
characters on g6 pawn captures and now
Queen - Quinta I ate with Czech and now
of course you can go to H 7 to guard the
g6 pawn however if you do this then you
get h4 and now you have a really big
problem on how to stop Knight to g5
rather you cannot defend that Knight to
g5 is coming and that's just it it is a
game over when when when it falls off
with Queen to h8 so after this Queen to
d8 check move we have Queen to f8
blocking but now Alireza just picks up
the the g6 pawn it's only temporary as
you don't really win upon here Giri goes
for Bishop captures an h3 with the idea
that if the bishop is captured in Queen
captures and f3 comes but Allah Reza
just continues developing rook to e1 and
now rush up to f5 attacking other races
Queen Queen to h5 and now Queen to f6
preparing to bring the rook into the
game and now Knight to g5 which is which
is incredibly strong as you're guarding
the f7 and h7 squares so you don't
really have the option of bringing
working to the game for example to EA
Taz now both rook and Queen covered that
square so we have Bishop to g6 now
kicking away the queen not allowing the
Queen to control the e8 Square Queen to
h4 and now we reach the critical
position where if had Giri gone a rook
to f8 for example the game just
continues and nothing important happens
however Giri played rook to e8 and this
move just completely blunders the game
but it's a it's a very beautiful move
and really a Sunday improver if you will
now so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on paying attention that the night
covers these two squares so if of course
the rook is allowed to e8 it's just a
game over for black so here ali reza
played Queen to h7 check so
congratulations to those of you who
found it and it's just impossible to
play this with black anymore now because
if you play King f8 Queen to h8 is
checkmate the knight and rook prevent
the King from reaching the seventh rank
so giri of course played Bishop
characteris on h7 but now there is no
longer the Bishop defending the rock on
e8 so rook captures an e 8 with check
and win the night covering the f7 square
only move his Queen to a faith but now
comes rock character skin captures in
Knight captures on h7 with check and it
was in this position unmoved 30 that uh
nigiri resigned the game and a brilliant
victory for ali reza fallujah who not
only wins this game but also the
Chesbrough invitational tournament so
really really exciting stuff
of course you resigned here after the
king moves you move the knight and you
are up a piece so yeah there's no point
in continuing this but yeah really a
nice nice short game and again another
one arising from the Berlin so it's very
very nice to see that the the Berlin is
sort of having you know a new life given
by by younger players and not just by
younger players by all the players and
new ideas are seen all the
I'm sure that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank you
Rakim Edward Smith James Norwood and
Michael Bogart and SEC Lane head orally
for our contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous video
Sarah thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Murphy saga and checking up on
everything that happens in the chess
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday and do check out the podcast with
MVL if you still haven't had the chance
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day